five kid Watchers not listeners Watchers
what is up this video is sponsored by
audible home to the widest likes of
digital audio books including the
bestsellers new releases exclusives and
so much more time honey go to
audible.com slash t fat K all lowercase
or text e back K to 500 500 to get
started that's audible.com slash P pack
K or text T that K to 500 - 500 to get
started now where's your glasses at
which one no hell no with you you with
glasses are we rolling
oh we roll bro I've never you never a
glasses off never really seen glasses
dude I swear to God every time I ever
think about you man sometimes um I think
about you with glasses on huh
because it's how you come across to
people in their imaginations with with
glasses I guess like reading brothers
yeah how about that when I get off stage
at the Laugh Factory
right away you go bro I figure out what
you look like I'm like why this front of
a bunch of the comics like what you're
like you look like a Rottweiler we got a
[ __ ] - you got that mic so you do man
that's your belt son you look here we go
to the strap maybe come get it
who wants it huh I'll tell you a few
guys aren't happy you got really Michael
Rapaport not happy yeah but he's in the
seniors division now what about somebody
that's still playing real well they're
not half a hog crystally a day well look
at he's not happy if you want the strap
come get the strap
come get it son you want a piece of this
who else
Sean Austin only hears cliff not happy
either dude Tony his cliff bro put on
some weight dude you can't wait 9 pounds
and compete heavy weight ok Tony hits
cliff looks like um he looks like a uh
he looks like he's been just run solely
on bone marrow man look at you don't you
have a skeleton this is just bone marrow
that's just kind of all over each other
yeah so yeah there Joe you're gonna take
a strong jellyfish and that's all he
looks like and you want the strap
daliyah come get it dude boy Simon rats
ain't happy Simon Rexy dude anyone on
the vote and come get it you want that
hitter come get it and I'm taking this
thing on tour with me every show I go to
you want the strap will be there you
want to get a pic with the strap come
get a pic with the strap dude but I got
Allen on my shirt today that's a legit
Bell that's interesting shirt did is a
beautiful belt man a little chip out
right and anybody wants a Michael
Rapaport you want to do quit crying
about everything bro and come get back
in the game dude are you gonna shoot
with him tomorrow and he's not happy
who Rappaport yeah he was shooting this
comedy bit together tomorrow he's not
happy I wouldn't be happy either he got
beat by an underdog and he just you were
the dog uh-huh
you were the under it's a Cinderella
story really dude it's not Cinderella I
think it's more masculine than that I
think it's more of like a male like
sender turns in the road or Yahoo oh
yeah oh yeah yeah but yeah man I thought
you were glasses man that's strange
because yeah you all the time I've never
worn glasses really never Dan what do I
wear this with dude a crown I don't know
you may just wear that like a tank top
your life be without mullet nah man this
isn't a mullet dude bro that's a moment
if I've ever seen one use the same
mullet that John you know John Kruk is
John Kruk yeah yeah you guys you and him
have the same haircut do we really bring
up John Carew a golfer nah baseball
player something to John Daly's you know
John crook John crook boy everything was
a triple we even on cocaine
yeah yeah saladboy son looks like he ate
his family that brother
dudes a legend you know boys bloated in
me yeah he doesn't but it actually looks
no bloating and that's back when you can
do cocaine and play a lot of these guys
so they couldn't handle it yeah how do
you how do you do a bunch of cocaine and
stuff tits though like that's the only
thing that tempts me to do some coke I'm
not done in my life that's the only
thing I get shred city son yeah oh do
you would be City bro dude look I could
do that works at a chevron bro that got
stung by bees dude look [ __ ] get your
life together
looks like he's on soy cocaine that's
why he's got them titties to estrogen
heavy of tofu cocaine got that tofu tip
oh man this here is powerful though yeah
yeah beautiful hairdo would you ever go
something different with your hair
I don't know I seen about this morning
let's do my hair wet god what a shop man
should do something I said what if I
went to a real stylist I wonder what
they'd be like you should do this yeah
like an actor you ever gotten like
somebody knows here uh-uh
yeah that make sense no I started cut my
own man I don't trust this man that's
been cutting mine over there by Floyd's
you cousin Floyd off Lincoln I go to the
one off of uh there's one off a
wheelchair and Lloyd doesn't mix up
though because you go to Floyd's and you
know I don't know the qualifications be
up Floyd's everyone's got in their own
business yes Floyd's it's a lot of
violent lesbians too a lot of people
that have misdemeanors yes Jews
piercings of the nose oh yeah everything
yes it's like one lady had both of her
eyes pierce shut and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is it yeah most of them were came
here to be actors and [ __ ] didn't work
out on the resentful cutting your hair
and they look like [ __ ] no when I got
audition yes [ __ ] haters so they make
you look like [ __ ] because they can't
they they don't when you get in their
part that they don't that they couldn't
get in correct yeah it's a lot of that
out here man but yeah this thing is
awesome in it thank you guys so much
thanks to the voters you know what I'm
saying boy
this thing is real dude when your fans
was like yo if you're doing gets the air
belts this place give does belt so I
looked at the link I'm like damn that
sure looks legit send it to chin I was
like yo strike up these belts son wow
thank you guys man this is really cool
things you could have - son you don't
know that one
I'll be like Tim Silva he slept with his
belt who did Tim Sylvia the UFC champion
slept with his belt I'll sleep with this
thing dude I'll take this to the fights
who wants this thing max Ferguson
stuttering uh who's that other guy Mike
Payne whatever that guy is Brian Mike
Payne yeah you know your fighters you
you I'll tell you what you Max Payne you
want you back pain you want to go
virally shoot a sex tape in that haha
don't for the fans just wear that bit
strapped where am I gonna wear that
around my neck during sex now you put I
it real tight just around your area get
that dick out your that dark arts dick
yeah boy that D ad that [ __ ] dad
stick you know what I'm saying I got the
heart of a lesbian son and I'm coming to
a city near you that dads take you know
dad but you didn't bring that belt to
Calgary yeah we got next
yup I'm up in Calgary Yuk Yuk's and no
no man
were you gonna love you there yeah yeah
I'm excited how nice is it there the
whole calgary's dope it's like Denver it
reminds me a lot of Denver
yeah I've been in Denver remember it's
shitload of Denver where I was born and
raised yeah oh really your mountain
child huh yeah a little bit a little bit
city kid though really and where Denver
city of Denver yeah Denver's a big city
I was in poverty row
yeah different city I mean there's
buildings there there's cars going
through it for you Denver you get
somebody [ __ ] stabbed me with a
granola knife in Denver do you can tree
that's bold now it's not New Orleans New
Orleans a different type of sin you
can't get murdered in Denver man oh you
can go down to Montebello Five Points
some like that although five points
cleaned up right now yeah my fellows a
little hoodie a little hoodie but
they're just it's like some second hands
it's like you know that it's all in like
you know old North Face Jack no bro you
go to Highlands
that's where my brother lives yeah now
it's all white people it's all white
people's the suburbs a lot a lot of meth
going around them oh really
a lot of meth yeah a lot of meth and
also a lot of swingers I don't know if
you know this but if you go to Denver
you want to go about 20 hour 20 mile 20
minutes nor 20 hours there's 20 you want
about 20 minutes north of Denver
how is ranch because what these swingers
do is they they put pink flamingos on
their lawn oh I'll be there in the
winter I got that to make sense yeah but
that means they're down to part oh
that's a code like the Underground
Railroad uh older people having sex with
each other's couples Wow yeah because
back in the Underground Railroad of
slave times if you were cool with slaves
and you wanted to mix your house and you
wanted to have sleepovers with them then
you would put like a lantern outside of
your porch at night and they would know
that it was all good to come over and
like eating chills yeah and they would
know that it was safe to stop over there
yeah it's kind of like that without the
slavery yeah just get your dick sucked
dude I was in yeah yeah Wow so it's a
big swingers area yes sir well I wonder
why that's some white [ __ ] yeah I'm
saying it's white suburb [ __ ]
yeah blacks are sharing their life you
only sharing [ __ ] with each other you
know now though white people to get
bored with their nine-to-five and
they're just trying to watch the wives
get [ __ ] rammed oh I've had quite the
offers there when I have you yeah I
never did it to what come in what coming
I used to be I used to train soccer moms
in the morning 6:00 a.m. and they they
want you to come in with the husbands
well not all of them so much well no
I'll just say and I'd quite the off for
his bed oh yeah well I'm sure people
have tried to [ __ ] yeah but I'm just in
a swingers party dude I went I was in
Lake of the Ozarks Missouri and as we
were doing a stand-up gig I loved it
there yeah it's beautiful
and they me and this dude pull up this
young brother who actually this guy went
to jail is in all isn't jail right now
for murder hope he's listening uh he
might I don't if he gets you guys get go
to jail do you guys play in jail I think
they can have access somehow didn't it
that's all that I've told the inmates
praise God Trump did that I bet you know
you don't know I mean got a little
credit commissary you get your sticky
buns with some fire in the kid there
what if Trump said I'm unleash
fighter in the kid in all prisons across
America that'd be dope to term trial oh
dude I bet in ten years you and from
could be doing a tag team match to the W
somewhere I'm so down but I'll back to
your boy who's in prison listen so yeah
so I pull it so me and this guy is oh
now uh
my second marker hurt yeah swing her
yeah you know we're we here's what
happened we pull into this hotel and
this is the hotel we usually say that
we've been there before to do this gig
you know you do a one-nighter in Lake of
the Ozarks and you do the other two
nights in Columbia Missouri and we pull
in down there to Lake of the Ozarks we
walk up to the front desk of the hotel
we've been there before and they said
boys only girls only or boys and girls
only and I'm thinking like well [ __ ] you
know I think I'm just trying to get
these you know Ramada Rewards club
that's all I'm thinking you know I think
so boys home yeah I'm like what Honors
Program is this like is this you know
some sort of link at the Ozark unite
sure points yeah so anyhow dude they
have bracelets with these boxes and it
was a swingers had rented out the whole
hotel all they're trying to [ __ ] and
they didn't even know we were comin and
the the hotel had forgot that they had
this this monthly deal with the
comedian's way to go yeah so we show up
and we don't have anywhere else to go
and so they let us stay there for the
weekend we couldn't compete in any
activities right which is like they got
all kind of sex games and you would see
just like these couples rolling in with
those like push cards like
lake of Ozarks is exactly I'm trying to
be cool here this I wouldn't say it's
not the most beautiful oh it wasn't real
hotties dude and they had a couple of
people brought her brother and with a
meet see a couple of white older white
people the young brother and you're like
what is this and you could tell he was
that hitter brush yeah he's the cleanup
he was Albert Bell do you don't say it
now that soul skaters Tony Gwynn Bravo
he's a Mark McGwire it was a lot of Rick
Sutcliffe sand a [ __ ] tendon that
Tony Gwynn you know and a lot of the
couples look the same man and woman yes
so here cuts very similar haircuts yeah
and it was Midwesterners and they were
out of shape Oh Walmart fans not a lot
of shape yeah this is one shape yes it's
kind of a general shape
melting yeah kind of they're all melted
yeah kind of like gravity's buddy kind
of say you know I went to little Walmart
there we used to go down on spring break
my boy Paul Creighton had a experience
out of house there so we go on the lake
there and yeah it's the best
I went to Walmart to like pick up beer
and snacks and [ __ ] and I thought I was
in a different country yeah beautiful
country people though oh yeah beautiful
dude the probably don't probably don't
want to a swingers party there though
well it was crazy so we're there for the
weekend right and so we couldn't go to
any events we would go do our comedy and
well if you decide to start [ __ ] dude we
would have been the best men and
best-looking men and women at that whole
event if we would have walked in any so
the crazy thing was there was like this
big huge bingo downstairs he had like 20
of those what's that hand bingo thing
where you put your hands oh you talk I
know you're talking about yeah yeah no
it's uh where you touch different colors
yeah her City right hand blue left leg
yellow and the lucky United Nations be
twister your feet and hands yeah western
western good it's like yes but naked and
we do that in college do you really yeah
with who
girl okay get a roommate with three legs
Oh dick blue big mouth so you so they
were doing that downstairs but they had
like twenty boards all put together in
this huge conference room and they had
like 50 people playing just [ __ ]
priming the walls with come yes buster
nuts yeah it was uh I mean people would
also be sitting there having like a bowl
of so now like Fritos and like they had
like a hot new yeah it was just I mean
it was almost like a carnival but with
you no more cry like just hella crotch
at it you know yeah but then the crazy
part was dick yeah carnival it did it
can even some of the vaginas look like
dicks that were just kind of giving up I
don't want to be there
oh I don't know it was it haha I don't
know lay there's some banger swinger
parties yes how he invite only and I
heard it's just hot shadows down Howie
Mandel is a great story where he
performed it one he didn't know and he
showed up he said they some lady met him
outside and then they brought him in
through a garage door and next he know
he's performing everybody just [ __ ]
in this room and he had a perform plays
a ledger fifty what's the point
listen some guys like hey do that do
that good about the taxicab you know but
why would you hire a comedian swingers
party I think just as I grow shut up
here you're [ __ ] what are you talking
about up there look to the guy from
America gots town or some [ __ ] shut up
[Laughter]
um but the crazy part was the elevator
we came in push the elevator one night
and the doors open and it was this just
[ __ ] trolley bro and there's just people
[ __ ] in there and drinking cherry 7up
out of a two litre straight charity
selling man it's good it's nice do you
remember when it came out it changed
everything when I was a kid do I got 140
do you remember clear Pepsi oh it was a
scam yes something had the coloring in
there yeah something happened they made
a bunch without the coloring that we had
to get rid of and then the clear Pepsi
and I was like oh hell yeah I love that
stuff it doesn't make sense it didn't
make any sense but it sold for a little
bit it sold for a little bit people lost
their minds and one lady killed herself
she couldn't handle it yeah there was
all kind of crazy rumors going around
with clear Pepsi came out that was a big
deal and then the do they still make
cherry 7up I don't think so no dude I
remember one year mom didn't have a lot
of money or whatever so for Christmas
she got us like two-liter sodas you know
and she gave us all these two-liter
sodas and we just and we'd never had our
own two-liter you know we're little big
deal
oh dude we were shaking him up and just
spraying him all over each other's
bodies and [ __ ] licking the sugar off
each other shoulders it broke the second
glass
okay I remember that though and that's
the first time I ever saw cherry 7up
game-changer here [ __ ] that mountain
dude red though yeah but that's just too
much there's something too much going on
in there
now that Mamadou red to me it was just
it was just toxic yeah it was like it's
pure red there's too much red dye that's
why so 7up cherry was perfect is it far
until they can go over the top yeah it
was just a little pee was almost a week
yeah that cherry 7up
well the mound do Reds trouble bro yeah
see look at that guys in a garage
he's dying all they see they dye their
hair with that [ __ ] it's so strong see
that yeah I'm not trying to [ __ ] with
that yeah what do you think that doesn't
get that kid he's Irish now and yeah man
she's been drinking yeah he had it all
dude yeah that can't be girl free that
can't be good for your dick that little
kid leaves sugar in your stomach if
you're drinking a bunch of that you're
probably Mountain Dew white but now do
you guys think cold is delicious so does
terrible for you but if I'm gonna drink
one Mountain Dew Mountain Dew is nice
it's a lot sugar though oh it's so bad
for you but if you're gonna [ __ ] with
it you know I used to like as a kid but
I felt like I felt like a pure [ __ ]
when I drink around my friends I'm gonna
get done from the court playing
basketball I'd be around all my black
friends my drink of fresca really I
drink a fresco and my friends are just
[ __ ] out of me
fresco was like the last so do you could
drink as a grandparent
Yeah right before you just have water
I'm at my pinkie of like this [ __ ]
riders of fresca they're fresh though
ice cold but my friends enjoy [ __ ]
adults dude you're drinking frescas but
what else are you doing man who'd fresca
myself a nice grilled cheese oh my gosh
yeah
you sound like a 60 year old my favorite
drink the grit the fresh ass grapefruit
fresca yeah you sound like a lonely dude
on a picnic bro I know I know are people
still molesting kids dude I swear to god
we were like it's going down yeah you
know more white vans and [ __ ] right
you have vans are out they don't
make vans anymore yeah those sprinters
that's for celebrities yeah yeah that's
it but there's no like murdering bands
anymore yeah I don't think there's any
cuz I don't even hear like a lot of my
buddies have kids and none of them have
said that their kids have gotten you
know it's not as crazy it's not as well
as it used to be no well because now
like the word is out if you're on a
white van it's like you might as well
just write on the side I [ __ ] kid yeah
just out you know saying take em all
saying I don't [ __ ] with them I don't
[ __ ] with van out or the or the Easter
Bunny's yeah you did I like seeing rare
things man they used to have I remember
they had somebody called in our podcast
and they said they'd never seen a black
little person before Oh like a black
[ __ ] yeah and they had one in our town
dude and he had these dreads right this
dude named uh no Dante right no Dante
yeah
and he had these dreads bro and they
were heat they were so long he would
[ __ ] trip over him when he was
running bro but he was a [ __ ] G dude
yeah and he would play basketball but he
would like he would kind of cheat a
little bit cuz it was almost like sauce
sometimes you'd almost catch him playing
soccer but he was so fast you could
barely see it thank you kidding with his
feet but since he was sure you'd let it
slide yeah you'd let it slide now where
I come from we really don't know no no I
can't have that yeah man people I think
he was like a town mascot people loved
him and I don't know I love how you take
calls on your show you just take off how
do you feel tabbed oh I assumed there's
not too many people calling like talking
[ __ ] like you're not getting trolls and
stuff no we had a guy thought people
have difference of opinion we get some
stuff talking stuff your friends
opinions fine but it's no one's even
come back you're the worst comic ever
you [ __ ] suck you hack and then hang
up or anything I don't know I haven't I
haven't got much of that you're gonna
get a lot of people crying jerking off
we got a couple of dudes [ __ ] and
know even boy smells yeah I have to do a
good thing I'll do the voicemails
yeah people leave voicemails and then we
play them back oh that's super smart
yeah cuz some of these [ __ ] mooks you
can't have him just running no I figured
you had a producers control it like all
right caller seven we got we got Jamie
and doubts Jamie what do you got for the
three oh I feel I'm here
my boyfriend even really kind of ton of
coke and grew a mullet out you starting
to act a lot like you and are we gonna
make it you know yeah you gonna make it
at least two years in a row baby yeah
you got at least two years in yeah I
guess it's something like that man yeah
it's just people just juror it's a lot
of dudes that are just addicted to
jerking off boats and just struggling
struggling with jerking off all the time
bro that stuff's killing people I think
well your boy they do what you guys do
you jerk-off Jen of course man Wow
she looks like a sinker really he does
you really I could never picture an
Asian guy doing it when I pictured in my
head it's always a white guy doing it
yeah I gotta be honest me too it's
usually a white dude in the corner
interest in Shane over just like know
what like you thought what that's when I
picture dude my mom caught me when I was
young she opened when I was jerking off
right fool like I was having a party bro
yeah yeah oh I planned it but I just had
an alarm you know what are you drinking
off to oh just just the pure imagination
bro dude that's weak your imagination no
this is beckon imagination was good bro
yeah had all the filters you know that
yeah
oz Lo and I had all the filters on my
brain and I was jerking off to I
pictured you as a kid with a mullet and
you got you kind of you looked a little
bit like Joe Dirt and you got like real
short cutoff jeans your dicks hanging
out the front and you got this mullet
and you're like dirty I just got your
socks on
you just jacking off to like tool or
something
well my that's how I pizza first of all
thank you that's kind of the coolest
things I've heard of dude I would jump
up and down and jerk off on my bed my
thing was to jump to jerk off and also
be jumping on the bed at the same time
trampoline because it would get your
butt blot blood going in your body and
then you spray out farther oh wow that
makes sense
oh dude you could [ __ ] I mean you
could put a [ __ ] you could put a silk
mustache on a plant you know a plant
wants to drop side pocket boy you could
put that [ __ ] you could throw a you
know a beautiful little you know a
little
just a white word Kurt and you could
drop that [ __ ] mustache on a plant
from about eleven feet away
was there any but I don't porn as a kid
I didn't have magazines I'm at a cover
of this female rapper and Mercedes she
was bent over like a Cadillac after that
on yeah yeah but you were with you jack
on when you were young I mean I remember
if I saw like of what I remember my
buddy's mom had a brassiere one time
that she would leave hanging in the
bathroom not just going there so the
Brazil Oh bro I would tie it around my
[ __ ] face so that each cup like
leaned over like right and weird love a
little bit of nose but the nostrils were
covered so just the middle all this this
just that main Sachi the kilim versace
should we watch at your nose taint what
is this thing that little part your
septum no it's your name isn't it a
little guy a little bit you cover up so
you can almost restrict your breathing
Oh bro so I had a brief solely through
these [ __ ] just these straight up
titty heels yeah oh that's what used to
like this [ __ ] milk holsters broca's
smell the milk I could smell the skin I
could smell the nipple I could smell the
children I could smell all the years and
my buddy growing up all dude go straight
at my head and they do it I would jerk
when I was sometime when I was young
when I would masturbate I'd pass out
almost like that movie butterfly effect
yeah go back in time did he do that from
jerking off no he gets a bloody nose and
does it dude imagine if every time you
do it back yes so all these dudes just
keep showing up there yes imagine you
went back to what you were thinking
about man it was so much more powerful
then now it's just like yeah that's cuz
it's overrated you joined the 10,000
club you know I'm saying yeah like those
guys who hit 10,000 homeruns do you
think they give a [ __ ] about homeruns
anymore probably not no gets old
yeah a lot you talking about life now
yeah like breathing them Cal Ripken now
my dick yeah yeah it's too much but it's
a lot for kids man but yeah we went to
that swingers thing and we that elevator
opened up and I remember seeing just
this whole you know it was almost like
it was like you know that painting
Michelangelo did where those two people
are naked touching each other in the air
whatever thief
yeah sixteenth chapel it was like that
but it was like just a bunch of just
people just just guts and everything was
a titty like everything in there look
like at a smelled like Mountain Dew read
yeah it definitely had that [ __ ] dick
after scent
Fritos up front and [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
bag
dude I would through us at hide and go
sniff dude you think you're getting one
thing and you get another you know I
want that I went to a swingers party on
accident in Denver's below we're we're
parted up top went below it said do not
enter me my friends like he was like
bumping down there so we went down there
and we realized there's a swingers party
because that a sign on it
they had like rules but it was like I'd
say the ratios ten to one dudes he got
into girls not good not getting what
like the the seven girls that were there
in the seventy dudes I just felt bad for
him yeah girl let's get out of here they
were you tell their morale was not hot
yeah my self-esteem was not booming well
that's why you got to have like a robert
e lee type of guy in there you got to
have a straight-up william wallace
running up and down the you know the
live a them yeah to motivate these
chicks at our at us at a gangbang yeah
yeah yeah keep the morale high cuz if
reality hits ago what the [ __ ] am i
doing you don't need that yeah you need
to be passing out DSW you got Tony
Robbins dick game going I need that do
dropping knowledge after women joking
you can do this yeah man women who put
up with a lot dude you know they're
putting up with a lot out there so well
guys just a bus that not at those
swinger things man really well yeah
you're waiting in line and [ __ ] like
you're waiting for a ride or some [ __ ]
you know like you like uber for your
dick really I think yeah you gotta wait
man there's gonna be some other dudes
dropping some gifts off before you get
in there man before it's your turn to
get your five minutes of fame
what kind of shoes do you wear I would
wear those pool shoes I think you know
like this crime up aqua socks
dude nothing nothing makes a girl look
dry up fast an aqua Sox terrible idea
bro I might wear Uggs and that
I wish some always keep my feet warm to
know where Alex are my Yeezy 750 full
yeah you're gonna be back and make it
Boston nut oh dude I'd have to get my
butt waxed I think bro that's my thing
like I have so much hair my butt like I
walk if I'm hooking up with a chick I'll
walk out of the room back which is
nobody it's that bad it just makes it
I'm self-conscious about it you know why
don't you uh Brazil wax it I'm just
scared of that man I met a girl and she
waxes people's balls - yeah they called
it V and B button balls oh it's actually
the most common practice for men is it I
used to date a girl who specialized in
that and she she was like man 60% my
clients are men because they do the B&B
you want to come in I'm like what is it
she was balls in but they literally do
all that the taint and your booty hole
III girl try it once on the inside my
thigh hmm never again hurt I'd rather
get a tattoo on my [ __ ] face oh it
hurts so bad
I'd rather get that [ __ ] Nate stamp
you if you if you ever hear you ass like
if I could braid your ass there yeah oh
you should probably get it removed
you could embrace yell it down though
like it sparked it to the side dude I
had an uncle in he had so much hair on
his neck he would gel it down for hurts
cuz you didn't want to shave it off
because it was his hair and it was like
a thing against God
you dug down the thigh huh oh he jealous
whole neck hair down you might want to
gel the your you basically got a duck
tail hanging out the back I look like
[ __ ] man you know but nobody expects
anything out of me that's the best thing
you don't think you show up people look
you know people ask where's the honey
guy you know there's obviously been we
look like you've been stung by bees do I
look blow this no it looks like you try
to drink honey right out the hive in a
bunch of these guys they think I'm a
small [ __ ] blood you're small for
sure dude
I'd be so old to [ __ ] 200 bees
we're babysitting my face all the time
[ __ ] stung by a bunch of bees where
do you live at bro in a comb
you gotta tighten up bro you're gonna
get diabetes day you gotta tighten up
bro you got that beasts enrolled rat
[ __ ] okay cool Master Splinter one no
so you have no other choice like the one
in that Christmas play like that not
cool man Nutcracker the ranking Oh it
was like the leader of the people in
Vegas who sleep on there you know
there's a community underground you look
like they're the voice of the
underground I look like I run the
underground now you have a belt to make
you official have this giant [ __ ] rat
ever put in the [ __ ] don't pass the
Playboy that's what I'm gonna make is
that on the back don't pet the playboy
dude well the scary part is I start to
think is this the best i'ma look you
know yeah I'm going downhill me yeah
another year before people like oh [ __ ]
shops falling off like a [ __ ]
and Callens been falling apart man bless
his heart did I song the other day and
man I don't know if they're not I mean I
thought he was a look like he just went
to an early movie he looked like a
senior you know it was just weird I
caught him in a glimpse and was like oh
wow if the light hits his face right
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah but somebody
get this guy some jello you don't get
this guy of nice warm mask in some
cucumber you know well a lot of it's
just stress I think a lot of his skin
falls off of his body a lot it seems
like because of stress I almost you ever
seen that movie death become sir
mmm would they take that that that
potion and that makes them stay alive
forever but there's bodies that can't
keep out so the falling apart like they
have to spray paint they're scanning
never seen death becomes is it cool hell
yeah it's a classic ah you never heard
of it death becomes her that becomes a
is a classic forever would be classic
classic what movie yeah for the world oh
my god Meryl Streep oh I love Meryl
Streep dude well death becomes her one
of her biggest movies dude I'd meet two
with Meryl Streep bro if she named him
unto me not I wouldn't do it the other
way but I'd watch her jerk-off into a
plant oh wow
you get Goldie Hawn you got middle
Streep and then Bruce Willis is the
doctor oh wow that's a big movie son
classic dude I can't believe that um I
saw oh I went to Mitzi Schwartz funeral
last night oh how was that service on
Sunday yeah yeah it was interesting when
Jim Carrey was there that's my era yeah
dude it's pretty crazy to see him I've
seen him over there before at the Comedy
Store but it was just interesting to see
cuz he used to work there you know and
so I used to work for him to be back
there and like you know just seeing like
all the people that probably still work
there when he was there like the people
that were you know the waitresses and
stuff you just saw him having a good
time which was pretty cool you know do
you have the beer do you look crazy or
is he doing better now he look pretty
normal I mean he's always kind of looked
like a little bit of like a kind of tall
these days he is that long hair kind of
a tall lesbian sort of feature did he
cut he cut the beard I think he's
shooting a show for Showtime so I have
to kind of quit the weird kind of beard
act yeah yeah he may yeah I didn't see a
beard on him but he was having to see my
kids having a good time who else was
there talk to him I didn't talk to him I
just said welcome back and I was walking
down the hall and who else uh-oh Louie
Anderson was there it's pretty cool that
yeah he didn't have the beard who's
clean-shaven
you know his hair was really long though
like super long man it's kind of sad
that he's getting older it's like it
just because he's like the best he's
like the best of all time he's like a
conduit it's almost like it's not even
in his control it's like there's a
higher power that wanted something to be
so entertaining to us have you ever seen
this he only did a 30-minute special
have you ever seen it and you
he really might not be over honest he
released one special it was like 30 40
ish minutes I mean it's just good you
yeah yeah it depends and years ago I'd
watch I can't do that company's not for
me yeah so animated and he's doing these
impressions and I'm like oh my god that
stand up there's no way
yeah yeah yeah he would say I bet he
would turn a lot of people off because
he's so talented
correct exactly exactly if D'Elia were
more Joe like if he had more of a jovial
like goof if Julia we're like a goofball
I could see D'Elia almost getting to be
because D'Elia can move so well well
here's a goofball yeah but but there's
goofball level with Jim Carrey you know
what that's a good [ __ ] correlation
yeah as far as right now I'd say
obviously it's not on Jim Carrey's level
but as far as like that goofy stage
present where he's like yeah they do all
that yes
physical blessings to be able to do all
that you know he is his gifts like he's
so I mean he puts his arm out and he's
you know he's it's a farty feet from his
self yeah yeah have you ever seen have
you seen we've brought it up you ever
seen daliyah when he did the the lip
sync battle oh yes I was ridiculous but
he's so like gifted with that and yeah
I'm trying he's just so silly man like I
watch his Instagram videos and [ __ ]
cracked me up yeah he's uh he's uh he's
normally to me in a lot of ways and
that's a good kind of because because
with Jim Carrey
daliyah to if you watch Talia now but if
you watch that Jim Carrey video early on
spine comic like oh [ __ ] yeah I'd be
like being a white basketball player
watching two Allen Iverson highlight my
wife sure [ __ ] can't do getting yet so
I'm not gonna play basketball yeah I
think we got to enslave white people
dude so that we can eventually one day
be good at sports bro cuz otherwise
we're out we're out I mean name a white
player that one got for Boston he broke
his leg trying to play with how their
time about well for basketball best well
that's just yes it's tough you know
it's tough but you know we still hold
down so like quarterback
what are ya so quarter bad and then yeah
narcolepsy I think is he becoming a
sport like that's like a new white sport
like clay Hall who else do you see the
complete bat me oh that reminds me I saw
I was on Third Street with my family on
Saturday and there was a like a protest
going on for energy exhaustion syndrome
a chronic fatigue syndrome hmm and then
people were get on the mic me like I got
misdiagnosed by all these doctors and
you know they just said oh I'm tired and
it's cuz my work and then I'm a
condition where I'm tired all the time
oh well some of those people are just
[ __ ] lazy yeah that's why I said I
looked around said not one of you in
shape so that might be a problem dude if
I lay down for two days bro I get if I
don't if I don't get myself up and go do
something I could be I could be lazy
first of all if I went to seniors yoga
this morning dude I was that Oh
some of us [ __ ] challenging right
towards the end these see Aloha I don't
know if they're farting I don't know
what they're I mean it seemed like
anything could be a fart anything goes
one guy was on his math like nine
minutes I thought that dudes out dad
went back to the the comedy store thing
so Louie Anderson you saw Jim Carrey Jim
Carrey they had all blocked off like
they had it all carpeted the whole back
parking lot they had curtains they had
like you know check-in gas check-in and
everything it was a real deal Rogan show
up um no Brogan wasn't there yeah
I haven't seen him there in a while but
well he just shot his special oh he went
on vacation
oh nice good for him yeah homey he's
there I think he's back Tuesday Thursday
good for him man yeah dice yeah dice got
up and did some time did what now was it
just commenting on the relationship with
mitzi or was it like there's some funny
stuff it was some funny stuff like dice
had some funny stuff I don't I think
dices I always think it just seems like
a dick but um it's not even his act he's
also just a real dick you know I've
never I've never met him and I miss I'm
balls deep but especially old-school
kind of I'll watch it and I watch that
and I don't get it right but I'm not
saying he's bad I don't I'm no one to
critique comedy ya know I don't but I
wanted that kind of brand doesn't do it
for me but people love him he's [ __ ]
he was you
you get as big as they get inspired a
lot of people start expecting but I've
never met him yeah I mean I think he's a
great marketer and stuff and maybe he's
not really a dick but not you
he'll come like he would bring he
brought me on the comedy store stage a
couple times and he every time he forgot
my name right which is fine but like the
third time I'm like she's not putting
any effort in yeah it's like it's just a
lack of respect that's the thing at
third time it was a blatant liek a
respek and then I said money from the
back you know he's like who's next and
and I said it and then the guy said he's
like honey yeah I wasn't rather than
thinking funny and he had bombed bro but
um so I guess that made me personally so
maybe maybe the issues mine you know I
just have a personal you know that kind
of hurt my feelings no experience with
me yeah nobody care but yeah but it was
so he got up Paulie got up and it was
pretty wild man that's also been
powerful it was powerful he was like
kind of crying and like talk and like
Sheeran and he talked about they had a
comedian that got to perform they got
Argos Hamilton if you ever seen that
guy's really old he's always dressed you
know red and white yeah he looks like
he's dead but he's alive yeah and he got
up and he and then Paulie got up after
him and said that guy used to [ __ ] my
mom which was pretty cool everyone's
laughing yeah everybody's laughing and
then he's like Andrew Dice Clay was up
here he used to [ __ ] my sister he goes
so that was pretty Jesus L Paulie like
you know this talked about how what a
family it was there and and it was
interesting man I'll get up I didn't see
are seen him he might have been there
Howie Mandel might have been there I've
said it
Saget was there he got up he talked too
much so I could talk too much Kevin
Nealon was there just milling around he
didn't get up Roseanne was supposed to
get up I think I don't know she did and
that was stupid to pass you or no shoot
you were there after I was there after
so they got Tommy past me he kind of
look like a you know like a lesbian a
little bit but also like a man and Tommy
still not the time he's not there
anymore Adam no yeah time we got accused
of embezzlement decided let him go it
makes sense yeah can't have that you
can't have a little of it yeah it's
tough you could take five out of you
know you can take five off the top yeah
if you're cool yeah if you're cool well
than that probably take 20 off the top
it was a good time though huh yeah it
was chill man anybody could be a
comedian then it was like you just had
about
then get a ride over there right people
tell me in LA you know I've been there
in an hour
two years now two and a half and it's
you know it's always been I mean [ __ ]
the spot yeah that but you talked to
Brian talked to Rogen I talked to all
these old-school guys like dude in like
the 90s that place was they [ __ ] in
the early 2000 yeah [ __ ] ghost house
like there's no one around man that's
crazy if you get up at the water be two
people in the crowd Prabhas I once
performed for one dude in the main room
Wow as he was dying I did 40 minutes and
then drank his blood Brian might need a
transfusion soon for a young child
though from like a teenager girl who's
gonna give up that blood fire looks like
Bram stroker right now yeah he's in
there he's got but maybe he'll get a job
on one of those oh well he's got his new
show coming out too huh yeah he starts
filming next month right now he's in New
Orleans film and movie with Josh Duhamel
and Wes and making Fox making watch your
watch your titties and that's good but I
won't grab you yeah but he said let's
enjoy doing that movie so he can have my
said Theo yeah and he was white again I
think the fans demand it man's about to
take your job
dude I'll babysit his job whenever man I
appreciate you guys having me man always
appreciated I'm excited for you bring
that thing to Calgary and it seems
whenever we're calendar my boy Chris
LaBelle opened up for you yeah sure yeah
he's gonna do it he's good man is he
he's funny you got yeah you like him
yeah I'm excited I watched his uh some
of his stuff yeah we got Calgary coming
up we got Tim blur brewing how was that
place in Bakersfield huh place is dope
is it yeah what are you doing that uh I
think I'm doing an MA that's a good spot
man let me see I was nervous to do it
cuz I'm not experienced as you and it's
a it's a Brewing Company yeah so it's
not exactly acoustics for comedy and I
got downs like [ __ ] cuz I've done
casinos before it's like an open
ballroom I can't hear the crowd so I got
there that's a work it's the worst and I
was worried about that there but it was
it was great was it it was great
yeah the acoustics are the scariest
thing is if those are bad it's where I
can't hear anything I get off and all
get my opener my brother bye damn I'm
for an hour bombed like no worse in the
crowd like I can't hear [ __ ] you know it
is like bad hearing cuz you got hit in
the ears huh not great what yeah but you
out is like if you're doing a bit and
it's just [ __ ] killing I can roll
with it more you know like have some
other means but I would I can't hear
anything I was like and then I just like
speed through everything speed through
it but not that place that place is dope
but I drink there too they do
what's a brewing house oh yeah acres
fields not a lot going on Bakersfield
yeah a lot of uh now a lot of Fighters
come out of like stocked and in
Sacramento is it the same in Bakersfield
is it different a little different you
know to uh I don't know if you want to
go out after hours and Bakersfield what
I was really yeah a tough tough
blue-collar area okay boys like to drink
now is there a lot of us homosexuals up
there now no they don't that's frowned
upon up there oh wow yeah
well cuz yeah they might celebrate your
haircut up there oh dude a lot of
lesbians hit me up on the DL asking
about this cut asking about this style
it's basic it's a 1 into a 2 nothing
[ __ ] crazy on the sides 1 into 2 huh
yeah in the back don't touch the top
don't touch the back you got to thin out
the back and you just got to hope for
the best at the bottom and that's the
Lord doing most of that but I'll be out
there at June 23rd at Imbler brewing and
then July 6th and 7th I'm in Level II
live in Oxnard and I'm going to Chicago
the dates are on the books yet though
when Chicago mean Kalyn I'm open up for
count shooting a special June 20
something out there the buster sold out
both shows sold out with June 27th or
28th
I think it's July wouldn't it is it June
no it's June okay June money first
something out there when you out there
dude I might be in Chicago on June 27th
oh wait no I feel I feel like that's the
June 28th I might be there cuz I'm gonna
do a fundraiser this is July 2000 is it
not to July wait but that says June Oh
nuts I don't the [ __ ] on there's like 20
all right July 20th
oh it's been fun for about the same time
yeah what have you found maybe I'll try
to come out there and watch it or do
some time that'd be fun heavy off open
up for him are you yeah that's awesome
man he's shooting a special huh yeah
that's gonna be so cool I'm gonna do I
think I'm gonna do a show in I'm at
today I'm in to hit you about this such
pressure and it's on there so we can
talk about but I'm doing a show in June
at the ice house oh yeah yeah if you're
around dude I'd love to do it if I'm
around though ya know cuz those AZ 9th
and the 30th or 9th and June the 9th I'm
in town I don't know if that's what it
is I think I feel like it is or what
about the 15th 15th I'm in Calgary
Calgary is fun man yeah I'm excited man
Yuk Yuk's come on out Yuk Yuk's yeah try
Ithaca what else has been going on man
not too much dude oh uh what's that
oh we're gonna say I was gonna jump some
current events I was gonna take a hot
piss first yeah take it
all right I'll sit in here and talk to
Chen all right talk how you been Jenny
busy huh look busy but good happy it's
Chen e-ring sister races go chili Jenny
yeah Jenny sees races to me dude I went
on Jake it sounds Jenica no he said I
called guard Brooke some time but I
think this Jenny sounds like more
endearing like a chinny chinny doesn't
sound sweet thing to say dude do you
know the guys from JK news have you been
on there uh yes Kenny yeah my friends
are well my friend is real good with
friends with all those people that's all
you tube crowd they had like that kid
David so do you know that kid yeah I
heard of him
dude he's funny wait I've seen him
before on YouTube so yeah
is he the shorter guy cuz he's taller
and shut well Mike I think he's taller
he's chubby hmm dude he was so great
David so comedy yeah Oh David's Oso yeah
I've seen this guy Ron he was this guy
right yeah he's been around for a while
too like didn't happen to him might be
funnier if you guys have a lot of aging
people in uh-huh or any people in but
he's a funny guy no he's good YouTube
following and he's dude he was [ __ ]
entertaining I was blown away
he just says so many things that lead to
so many conversations also he's really
good conversationalist to that bro so
good and that show was great they have
1.7 million subscribers dude Bobby went
on there I was the only Asian to ever be
in there that I think in here yeah I
honestly think he's the only Asian
person that has been here other than me
right yeah dang dude you know what the
saddest part is it was kind of the first
group of Asian people that I ever really
spent time around and two of them are
Latino so it was this guy David's those
group that JK news okay but dude I had
so much fun and they were so much more
realer than a lot of time I expected it
to be totally different than it was
expect I guess I like their kind of like
just really to the point and like what
yeah blunt and like for factual exactly
how they feel huh it didn't seem like
they tried to like hide a lot of stuff
where is I feel like if we get a lot
more nervous about saying stuff
sometimes that's different than me then
cuz I kind of like hold back I think a
little bit dude they were to the point
that's good well yeah they're subscrip
their subscribers are crazy on YouTube
yeah they got a lot of a lot of fans and
what's going on these YouTube he was
telling me about a guy named David so
select him for a bro
you were yeah alright so I'm giving you
that damn bro I know I look like a I
look like a honey badger look like he
got stung by bees dude that's golden
bees should we do some current events
sure the guy's son du chien was saying
sorry
that the only Asian guest you ever had
was Bobby Lee that's it right trying to
think
that had to be yeah Wow
I haven't had any yet I'm only at four
guests well ahead all Eddie Bravo he's
not Asian but he's he could be Asian bro
you know you know or something he's I
think he's Latino
yeah be Mexican oh yeah yeah Bobby Lee
really of Elliott dude I gotta get some
Asian guys in here huh I mean who cares
but they're funny
who would you want on chin if we if we
let you pick any guests come in studio
um
comedian wiser any is the matter any
Asian any Asian just in the Asian aisle
we're trying to get homeboy on though
get the guy John Kim Jong yeah yeah that
would be awesome
he would be great so there you go join
you him on just Himchan that's all the
k-pop group or some [ __ ] in here if we
could get some k-pop members now receive
all dragon z ball one of those human
cattle some [ __ ] I don't know those
characters yeah um this kids funny David
so I don't if you ever seen him or not I
was on his show the other day called JK
news no I've seen it
bro this show this dude their whole
group was really really funny really
yeah bro is crazy yeah when I was out in
East LA and there's something I'm gonna
base want like Latinos Asians bruh and I
went to this thing once I'm downtown you
pay these two Vietnamese do is 50 bucks
they'll [ __ ] beat you up bro
they put your neck on it that you don't
you think you don't and that feels nice
because you deserve it bro what I don't
deserve to be beat up
we all deserve it what did they do to
you they would if a guy came up to you
right now points you in the [ __ ] face
right and said you know what that's warm
walked off I wouldn't know but could you
think of something maybe it could be
been awesome okay look if that's how you
take it then that's good sometimes our
fates are being awesome alright thanks
man dude that's great I would be like oh
[ __ ] is a million cut that one guy off
oh I would tell brothers a million
things I could think of
not for you but for me you know if that
happened to me see I'd like that makes
sense
I'd punch me in the face - yeah I have
the audacity to think of buying a
McLaren you know what you should punch
you in the ass but if you're like [ __ ]
man that's for being awesome nothing
you're so right on bro yeah thank you
thank you
but yes change the favorite now couple
vietze down there with just body you
know just a lot of body blows you put on
one of those dog bite suits it's 50
bucks they beat you for 10 minutes
breaking the nuts and [ __ ]
yeah you can't figure nuts you can't
feel anything in that dog bite suit but
you can feel just you can go head trauma
though oh nothing nothing you couldn't
handle brush can't really but you might
not be able to handle it if you have
something I had a few yeah yeah no but I
don't know if I want I don't see what
I'd get out of it you've probably
already had it you probably got a
built-in after whatever happened to you
you just feel like you like you need it
yeah oh I feel like I deserve it that's
like I deserved it and I almost died and
I tipped him afterwards and I [ __ ]
deserved it you think did you bow I
don't think I bowed I just I don't think
Vietnamese people do any of that
they're just show up engine yeah they
don't yeah they shook you up
they eat [ __ ] you up or whatever you go
hey could you food afterwards no but
they had food outside they had a truck
one of those lady Holland's but they
beat your ass yeah Rowan yeah I felt
good but anyhow so that's what it was it
was down there and it was this place and
it was just awesome man it was wrong why
don't we I don't know what you tell me
what day I'll get us some Panda Express
nice meal and go down there get our ass
whoop at least you payin Express and
bumper cars you know can you do bumper
cars er cuz you can't do a lot right
yeah they don't make bumper cars anymore
cuz 2:19 but I hear you nope they sure
don't feel oh you know bumper cars just
you sue them yeah rails bumper car your
neck what's a my neck would snap oh yeah
yeah I'm fun like stare at the hot chick
my brothers come [ __ ] side car you
can sue these days it's so messed up
there's somebody dying off a peanuts and
bumper cars when I was young [ __ ] them
they're out you know I agreed you're the
weak link
yeah it's like adult asthma maybe God
don't want you down here maybe you don't
want you breathin yeah yep if you came
breathing you shouldn't be alive it's a
sign not saying I need you up here more
yeah yeah if you can't take a couple
hits off the universe then
haha that's it you drive a bumper car
get the [ __ ] out it we got to get some
Asian man I need to get some Asians in
my life I realize that a couple vietze
do you like Asian women
I gotta get a couple Latinos like Asian
women I think I like him I met a Korean
girl one time yeah and this was in Idaho
Shinzon listen he's a Lycan I don't know
you too well
her legs wouldn't come apart though she
had you ever getting like chopsticks
that are real too hard to get at the top
they won't like a mermaid
she's a korean mermaid yeah she was kind
of mermaid but with two legs oh you
ruined a mermaid you tried separating
the mermaids [ __ ] maestro I don't
know the Korean mermaid mean [ __ ]
realize it [ __ ] his shoulders get out
okay I tried for like three minutes so
God's plan you know well or you've
ruined this plan it's plants fruit the
dark arts to meet a nice mermaid Crean
mermaid and you [ __ ] their life of it
you can't oh oh yeah dude do you think
are you wanna Asians not your style
though oh I like it I think here's my
issue sometimes that I have around seven
agents so attract do you oh yeah I feel
like I don't know I don't understand the
vibe you know like like if it's a white
girl like I just grew up around white
girls or a girl yeah
so I get the vibe I get if there is a
vibe or if there isn't but around a lot
of Asian people I haven't been around
them much so I'm not know how to act
yeah I don't know what is if they're
flirting if they're not flirting
it's like you have to tell so now that's
like agent people can't see white people
that's dad yeah not really
yeah I don't think so I just feel like
they don't they don't recognize me
yeah they don't see me or they don't see
you maybe it is tough it is tough I chin
you have ADD I'd say you have a dry
sense of humor yeah for sure
do you I don't know what imagine it's
tough yeah you don't know if he's upset
if he's happy yes okay that's it like
you could have thought yeah you're tough
- yeah you just get a disown give you a
Ferrari or did your dad die yeah I don't
know yeah I do
that's a thing and I think they keep
their joy inside because like
we're just so verbose and like showy you
know and I think Asian people they keep
all their joy inside well and at the end
of their life they like whisper to
somebody and say they were happy and
then they go to heaven that's what I
think but I don't know anything also we
had one group in our town cabrona called
whites against Mexicans and we didn't
have any Mexicans and then they actually
end up trying to beat up an Asian kid
one time after I channel their anger
towards the the the because yeah they
didn't know and then they used to call
us Mexicans growing up just because my
brother had real dark skin and I had
kind of olive skin oh yeah meat I hear
you I my friend Cody diamond he's now
one of my best friends end up being a
real close friend he was a fighter right
funding of scene it was eventually when
my training partner his coaches but when
I was in college we got in a fight in
downtown and I'm gonna fight with his
friends here and know me at the time and
I'm always tan and other big dude and he
said you were tanning know I'm always
tan
I was I was running outside to us extra
dark right and someone separate me and
his friend are shower running around boy
yeah
big brown on it down and cook it got it
down a dude Joe Rogan would eat you bro
let me tell you this in the world and
shoot me in their cell in a hardcore bro
you need my ass versus me Oh hundred
percent bro
he'd make four thanks takes out of
everybody's ass my ribs like the [ __ ]
beef ribs bro he'd be just grilling
[ __ ] and catch them his mouth dude
that guy he'll cook anybody I bet he's
killing people out there and cooking I'm
good chance out of camp broken but my
champ bro put my friend Cody D off so
you didn't know me the time to shut your
[ __ ] mouth you Mexican I Wow
yeah yeah you see about a sec skin Wow I
get a lot of that yeah I could see it
man you've almost been beaten into a
couple different ethnicities to from
taking those punches like your face
swells up not too bad though really I
stay Brown you know I'm saying yeah I
don't see it I feel like yeah you're at
right now you seem a little bit more
like Czechoslovakian like he could be
like vlade divac's [ __ ] kind of
handsome
really do you like that man Detlef
Schrempf stalking adopted brother like
shrimps [ __ ] malnourished the dump if
you step bad beat I look like dead let's
rip and shrek had a son dude broke to
BYU three nine feet tall to be white to
play in the NBA
yeah ten foot tall and just cool man
it's just black dudes beating you up and
then you have to retire indeed correct
what are we talking about man how that
lips rubs your step down
yeah we gotta get we got to get some any
more agents on your show yeah I need
more agents man we're gonna get so we're
gonna get some I need morning but I
gotta get fine-tuned II guess we got a
we got an escort that came in like a
real escort my gosh huh like a hooker um
yeah I think she's pretty girl you know
you find her
I don't know Internet I just wanna kill
on the show she wanted to get some
things off her chest bro would she get
off her chest
um I mean she has small tits good but
yeah but that's okay and a lot of me
well that's miss it he white she was
white but small tits big ass
nope small ass - OH mm maybe that's
going off here I know that's what it
seemed like let's say being a race car
not having you know nitrous or yeah and
being real you probably not be a race
car you know ya be Lightning McQueen
maybe that's how she look like light
McQueen like just no you know just jus
just basic she weighed about 80 pounds
okay this is a terrible sport
yeah that's like showing up for the
NASCAR and there's a Prius in the back
you know [ __ ] man it's doing yeah it was
uh but anyhow so yeah we had an
interview with her what was she talking
about the struggle she was talking about
how she used to work at a peep show and
and uh like dudes have put money in and
thing would go up and then they would be
back there with all these toys or if
they felt like [ __ ] and they're like and
she said there was up on the other side
of the wall where the dude was there was
always a bunch of the
you know jeezum back there and what
jeezum you know jerking off okay and
that the guy they couldn't even chisel
it off after a while it got so hard on
there and that crazy mr. power oh geez
I'm right there oh wow so how old was
she
she's about I think 37 now oh she's long
in the tooth yeah she definitely losing
some gum what'd she do now she still
does escorting and uh she also I think
she makes beats they're just gorgeous
crazy with this you know that's what's
happening like things are going well for
it yeah this is the people I know boy
that's the champ you wanted the champ
you got all is uh you got all those
friends you know the right seniors broth
of [ __ ] princes the Rat King boy
let's get my teeth of my tail baby the
Rat King is here dude the Rat King and
the bee sting we're [ __ ] I look like
Tom Brady and Shrek had a [ __ ] kid
[Laughter]
dude your finishing move is the
anaphylactic shock
you [ __ ] you're [ __ ] out there
raisins bees dude you look like a
[ __ ] bad to WHO that got better but
it's also raising bees dude okay like
[ __ ] wolves have been teething on
your ears you look like baby wolves have
been teething on your ears
you idiot let's do the news do you have
women's shoes in here what the [ __ ] you
guys a game of throne kicks hey keep
your [ __ ] gasp um I guess I mean
you're prostitutes
looking for [ __ ] oh dude the news Jim Oh
what do you think of this chick first of
all you yes right yes I here's some more
pictures of her all right okay not mad
that one's not that guy was a little
creepy well did you hear about that girl
that was sending some guy 65,000 texts
after one date that's her that's her
that's her in pictures but this is how
she looks when she was caught she's
still hot
she's not bad using the UFC fighter
what's up like a woman she looks like a
female UFC fighter no a really good
person hold up scroll up that's a Hitler
lover so she she called herself some
sort of a female Hitler so oh she's
crazy yeah so she sent him 65,000 texts
she drove from like Florida to Arizona
where he's at and then broke into his
house to the bath in his bathtub hmm and
she's I feel bad for her she seems kind
of like out there she looks guest:do
she might be bipolar huh so out bipolar
go back it says another message she
wrote don't ever try to leave me I'll
kill you I don't want to be a murderer
well what would I do with your blood I'd
want to bathe in it yeah I found your
next guest call yourself the new Hitler
maybe she should let Kalin but he didn't
sell of it do you want to hear some of
them yeah did she sound crazy she sound
crazy she seems like like crazy but I
don't know if she would do anything
crazy ha she's a chiller like quagmire
yeah she got that man after just one day
at one point she claimed to be his wife
she showed up at his house broke in took
a bath and sent him thousands and
guileless a little text message I've
told this usually I got it down a bit on
a road trip from Florida
look why should breathing like that I
guess love
she says she met the victim online last
summer on a site called Alessi I met him
online I was looking for my healing
angel the something I meant told me I
would meet a healing angel she's
completely out there psychics lead women
astray since that time the man has
reported her outside his home and for
threatening text messages
police say Addis sent 65,000 text
messages to the victim sounds like a
[ __ ] can't handle that no this is a
down as a girl thing I told him if he
ever blocked me on whatsapp that I would
come and move here so he blocked me Wow
come here okay so she's loyal well you
know she's a woman of her word I'm sorry
I don't see the problem
this guy must have such a strong dick
game he can pass up a loyal woman like
this yeah you know what bothers me say
some oxygen for the rest of people in
that room god damn
she might be on one of those oxygen
loading things where they you know where
you takes a while yeah yeah and and you
load up so you can hold your breath you
ever done that where you load up and you
can hold your breath like three or four
minutes underwater no you can look on an
on line it's like oh wait I've heard of
it and they say that's a david blaine
broke the record now say that's cheating
yeah it's definitely eaten mullets I
mean it's you Errol Flynn used to do
with the guy on Tarzan because he would
do scenes rated to be underwater for a
long time Wow and he could hold his
breath like seven minutes but they
that's how you do it yeah you just keep
loading I don't know if she did that I
think she has some sort of problem oh
yeah that could have been it yeah I
thought she was trying to be in a
contest or something but she could have
a problem yeah but yeah she seemed wild
she seemed a little hot in those
pictures but yeah he was never real at
all she got kind of a medium neck like I
got she's hot as hell there no that's
what we want and I want to be careful
always sake he's probably looking at
Chandler energy somewhere else I don't
want to be on the end of that dude how
many guys are kind of like turned on by
this because I feel mildly erect by this
me too I'm a little round myself yeah I
don't know if I could handle that dude
no I can't handle that dummy text
message I'm gonna have to block you
myself but yeah if you could channel it
back to how many
a hundred a 500 a day 500 we can turn
our back to five a day I'll [ __ ] with
you yeah yeah and and and don't takes me
after 6 p.m. or before 7 a.m. yeah we
don't ever call yeah don't tag me on
anything on Instagram Twitter yeah stay
out of my life
you basically yeah until this dick needs
please but no you're right yeah okay not
bad no definitely we got to get these
dicks out there okay what else this one
where a giraffe head-butted a director
gang gang where I'll respect this [ __ ]
oh man have you see this no but I know
why I do because Hollywood shows up into
people's neighborhoods people's towns or
whatever think they can do whatever they
want right you drive don't play them
Hollywood knows no repercussions dude
that's why you know the only time
Hollywood ever came to my neighborhood
they you know people oh they wanted to
get video of somebody saying we saw an
alien or something you know like oh I
saw that video they got in I'd always
the leprechauns yeah I saw the
Leprechaun tree but it's the only time
it's always income and just to make us
look stupid
yeah so guess what we're [ __ ]
striking back head button yeah you want
to [ __ ] with regular people you want to
[ __ ] her regular animals you're in
Africa and you're gonna go [ __ ] with a
what is that animal again giraffe
giraffe for sure no that's a traffic
yeah a long animal you're an idiot
well this what's interesting too is
here's they told because he's shooting a
dhaka bout giraffes which I'll probably
skip that documentary but yeah and
boring it's a draft but the boring but
the thing is is they told him don't get
too close to the giraffes cuz there's a
risk of this he didn't listen he got
close and out if you ever seen drafts
fight they swing their necks mhm well
that he was right up on the draft the
draft swung boom headshot
dead he got necked up bro and they
talked to the guy who owns the sanctuary
and he's like he disobeyed the rules
like this is draft doing draft [ __ ] went
up on the draft down raft on a raft dude
and if you get you know I'm saying if
you start especially if you if you trail
along the drafts neck guess what's at
the top a [ __ ] head you need to get
burned you're gonna get stripper buoyed
by
dude but how they have horns here's a
little factory - I struggle sometimes
with spelling as a kid you really I
could see that not anymore though well
your hey the mullet so um but I used to
think giraffe was de RAF it talks about
23 no drafts a black dude bro I know I
know
yeah it's a real storm I thought it was
a de RAF fight you public education they
let me slide our rafts no ever said
anything look at them for coupons over
there and porce is a crazy du brah I
just got this Bouldin retriever right
here I got all the [ __ ] mammals
you got those de RAF the longest until
my friend Shane Carwin he's the educated
man went you know it starts with a G
Riley shut the [ __ ] up he was I swear
Allah college education two degrees no
ever said [ __ ] do that a kid in our town
him robitussin turns this black dude
that's a great name it was beautiful eye
doctor um nope I think he actually did
enough work in a medical facility though
but I don't know and what facet ya know
but this is a long time ago robitussin
mr. Roberto yeah Robi they called him ro
bro yeah Robi robro I'll row
yeah people probably call him row row
Oklahoma Robo we had a boy named dressed
to kill in our town and he uh will wear
church socks all the time and the crazy
part is he ended up going to jail for
murder
hey hey ho so that's why why did he do
it what else you got who knows another
one Walt Park one so this is infuriating
family a French family went out of their
vehicle to a cheetah can't trust
enclosure that's what you get you French
out boy the French get out of the
vehicle yeah which tells a kid died here
kid
no there's no deaths or anything we're
fine I'll show you the video though
right now I think is agent don't care
somebody died they don't shooting
actually it's normal day so this is them
it's not them
another crowd following come on those
people
so these the French I always taking
pictures outside and then you can see
them running back to the car I know
they're kids there but they don't [ __ ]
with those people so look how close
together there's actually stalking him
right now see that oh my you're close
but they don't want to kill him because
if they wanted to they just want him out
of the territory wanted the baby oh oh
[ __ ] where's the baby in their arms
right there
Oh Mike but the baby gone on its own oh
my god those parents should this just be
slapped around yeah and that's this is
them before you'll see him or hear out
of the car taking pictures of the
Cheetahs [ __ ] how stupid the only
thing they've ever Guinness was fries
yeah oh the French dude and giving up
early on stuff that's the most French
thing you could do
we're in big hats women and men looking
very similar and wearing slick in their
sideburns bag
not washing their hair all the time
what's other French we up dude
hollandaise sauce wigs wigs what a salad
dressing yeah dressing this do the front
bro there's nothing you can do than be
[ __ ] if your friend if your being
French bro say stay at home for me you
know I should just hire those Filipinos
already were saying just to beat them
down but without the dog suits a couple
vs bro yeah a couple vs yes oh I put 50
bucks on a couple of French dude I'd pay
for a couple of friends and you know pay
and express either afterwards it's the
most French [ __ ] you can do get out and
touch our an animal with your kid yeah
you get Cod that's imagine they get out
to get a kid and then their kid gets
killed by an lion
that's happen God cheetah son mother
nature's ready to strike back yet I'm
telling you this stuff starting in
Hawaii the volcanoes volcano some scary
[ __ ] and people think it's like aspecto
so they get out and watch a [ __ ] that's
a monkey a volcano is a world melting
and exploding up and on fire you know
and saying that is I said we're used to
movie July oh cool that's that [ __ ]
that's the the
Earth's magma firing at you people
taking selfies and [ __ ] dude there it's
just a big nut Brian that thing just
straight up is busted out yeah
dude there's a video of a guy cooking a
hot dog walking along the lava like with
a Hot Dog on a Stick cooking the hot
brush though I mean that's awesome
lava grilled dogs bro you could sell
that on the Internet open up a pop shop
while the dogs we just saw this about
Wiz Khalifa talking about potentially
going into MMA that's not real is it
this is all you do is I'll show the
interview right here with Tim's when I
see who is like 30 pounds good to see
you man have we talked to Jay Glazer the
other day he said you could go pro if
you really wanted to Jays just joking we
were trying to make a fight
[Music]
but would you would you ever the
continued like getting into Bellator UFC
or anything like that like Bellator
fight some fun or what yeah like you got
to pay me a whole bunch of money to get
me to fight so absolutely man
Wow oh man see that that's a product
that's the same you know you can stop at
you and this is st. you so Callen pays
this rich do to teach him tennis and
count things to get at tennis I said I
would you pay that man he tells me oh
that's his job to make you believe that
you get at tennis he's paying that man
same [ __ ] here with riskily when I've
seen him hit mitts
I've been around a few myths I know
people can fight really he can't fight
he can't so he's creating Jay Glazer a
shitload of money and Jays really you
could do this Pro nothing [ __ ]
things even fight pro do you think he
really believes that he could fight
right now
yeah I do unfortunately do you think he
who would they fight him against
somebody like what about 675 Demetrius
Johnson five weighs about 115 125
what about that redneck guy that fat
that white guy Roy no no ray cumin 20
I'm watching no he's a heavyweight I'd
watch that but no no number ten if they
are fighting be him and then Roy number
ten we don't want that
I'd watch I'd watch him verse anybody
else with Lyceum Khalifa dude isn't
there a hooker with named Khalifa
stripper you know there's a there's a
there's a porno star yeah she is
bad oh yeah she falls on Twitter I
watched Empire he does yes oh no Meah
Meah Meah Khalifa yeah I watched him
burst Mia and me let's say she go when
she looks way stronger than him
she definitely stronger he's like nine
feet tall man and walk straight up yeah
hundred pounds yeah that's crazy dude
yeah be like trying to walk through a
force and you got like a branches near
you that's what it would be like if you
see Mike moving one of his arms well it
would be like fighting Jack Skellington
from [ __ ] the the Tim Burton movie
yeah Nightmare Before Christmas oh yeah
he's like a real-life Tim Burton I love
Christmas dude yeah so what I'm thinking
about milfs to do that all these dreams
I had this dream that I was at this at a
airport with those water in it and all
the lifeguards were milfs bra no yeah oh
yeah and I've been having that dream and
it was Christmas time do you want to
grab jacket huh mm-hmm
I don't know Chloe used to jack off in
his sleep though Wow would be terrible
yeah he had a tough time with it and he
um and they made him wear these jingle
bells on his wrists after a while
don't wake him up yes I make sense yeah
I don't know if it makes great sense but
it was effective and cheap yes
what is this else about sorry I
interrupted you know it's what everyone
else get you damn I know all right so
this is what you came in here horny
today dude I am horny bro something's
wrong with me dude not for someone's
right yeah but nuts nuts are filling up
you're on the testosterone ewwww
nah man I'm off and I thought about
getting back on it but your hair I
thought my hair will fall out no that's
not true
you don't think so no you you know it
would do your favor if it's pulling back
from here [ __ ] you [ __ ] so much here
whatever what we are we are on tier 2
your testosterone replaces no I stick
testosterone back in the day to go to
the gym you know I used to do help what
difference there's some steroids and
testosterone the test your levels and we
like do I need more energy or leaner
muscle mass and they put you on the
correct dosage oh wow and you'd shoot it
every week on do you ever do that
no I prize should yeah would you but you
can't go back and fight anymore right
well no I wouldn't know right but you
yeah you wouldn't but if you took that
stuff now you definitely couldn't you
couldn't my bill do Bellator can fight
in UFC though right do you feel
sometimes like that vile like that you
had an aggression at that time that's
not the same now like a son yeah cuz
I've never seen in your face but I
couldn't imagine you like I couldn't
imagine you as a fighter no I don't mean
that any offense you know I don't
offense take and yeah a lot of people
can't like I was watching the fight
Saturday my girls family's in town
they're staying with us watching the
fights and her grand was like I can't
believe people do this and then some was
like we know Brett in fact she's like no
and she's like why this goofball
and then we had to bring up highlights
she's like what and I was watching like
oh it's a different dude that's a
different game that's cool though man
that's great this I mean it way that's
cool
just to go to different do be able to
take on different things and you know
and uh and stick to them that must've
been the heart was it so hard to just
keep training and that kind of stuff
I love the Train I still love the Train
but it was just it was so stressful and
scary for me
yeah stressful and scary and where
there's some animals out there and that
support I mean there's no savages yes
ma'am yes God
phenomenal fighters straight scares me
bro me too
scares me a lot and I get scared of that
having to really fight somebody like I
can fight somebody that I could beat up
you know yeah but to really fight
somebody man and after really yeah it's
not gonna be easy
there was no easy fight no swords all
good no hatchets brought nothing dude
did anybody ever try to like sneak
anything in their waistband like you
couldn't do anything ever like a blood
sport like put salt Meyers something
like that crunch it up like Chong Li
yeah glass up your knuckles or something
no yeah man I wouldn't she I would
[ __ ] put some cinnamon between my
fingers right there something more you
know I would do something you know we're
hot a little bit of pepper right there
my knuckle oh wow you know that's gonna
help I think it get up a little if you
get pepper in one of somebody's eyes and
one eye then you're fighting like a
one-armed in the eye and they give you a
warning yeah but that poke they you know
that pepper they might not see it it's
so small you know or glitter even the
glitter they'd see cuz you ever if you
miss the eye you're gonna get it on the
cheek and they're gonna see that I don't
know I got to think of some more
strategies but I wouldn't be the best
fighter though it's not for everyone
watching I'll be the fear bear that
would be my fighter name there'd be the
key Rat King bro yeah King dude some guy
would just take me made out of looking
steel is it really it's a steel cage
with rubber over it ah hard as [ __ ] I
could do more of a wooden cage
everything what does that do
winter Sun yeah but that's right now
with a little [ __ ] hold on I just hit
me you know either only dude and threw
on a teen who strives for a mullet yeah
you do you know you're the only guy who
rocks the mullet bro no I know I don't
know it I see tons of people I never
seen a teen [ __ ] rises to anything I've
ever seen another man with a mullet of
purpose there's some haters out there
right no man but you just keep rockin
people are afraid boys step into the
hair cage you know I'm sayin boy I'll
see you in the Octagon bruh I can't
imagine with a different haircut in the
wooden hair cage dude I'll take on
anybody any barber rat King don't care
do when I grew this I reckon okay when I
grew this out there this thing changed
my life man yeah things started going
better when she grew the mullet you know
I just felt like more serious I don't
know if they did or not I don't think
they took me serious anyway but I didn't
take myself seriously try to look I was
always concerned about how I looked
yeah and now I don't care at all really
oh you're good looking dude it's not
like you're hideous I'm an eighth bra if
I take cake I'll brush my teeth always
number number it's a little snowman you
know eight solid I would I definitely
give you a eight really yeah if I'm not
an eight and a half man if I brush my
teeth I'm an eight I would say you're an
eight you possess skills - you're funny
I don't have a lot of skills though you
know my skills are very I've some skills
that I keep secret and then I have some
dark magic know just different types of
stuff you know not gonna say some of
them but then some skills that people
know about it that they're not very that
I'm not skillful at comedy or skillful
at yes dig that yeah chicks dig it son
but they do get more some other people
out there you know people that didn't
[ __ ] win the [ __ ] strap you know
like Chris D'Elia Delia gets the ladies
bro that's fine dude have the ladies bro
let me see you get find them once you
find about a it's about a seven pound
strap-on seven pound lady can wear
around your waist do what Delia is
tucked in at night with a
Pease you're tucked in with that belt
you tell me who's lonely or what say out
Julia yeah well you're busting nuts on
in women he's busting nuts on belts yeah
I'm polishing up this [ __ ] belt with
the truck body [ __ ] baby you know I'm
throwing out that frickin straight-up
Louisiana Combe out of my B's bro oh my
god is that what I said
that's pretty much is that that mean
yeah it's pretty much all right what
does that think for ya oh this thing
yeah oh this is last night they had this
at the car getting in there yeah it was
funny you got in there and the wife
still wearing the wristband no I don't
know water park or some [ __ ] yeah want
to keep it or something do the water
park was the thing bro remember that it
was the thing even back then I didn't
wear aqua Sox is just I didn't celebrate
never but you seem like that kid that
like bro but you're like the biggest
[ __ ] kid were you always know I was a
late bloomer really well yeah but I
always had the mindset that was bigger
than anyone so my nickname was Biggs as
a kid yeah you know why cuz you were big
you know I promise my friends call me
Biggs is that always thought I was
bigger than I was no because you as I
was small yeah no well you don't know
how things work though yeah because you
need a mirror I mean every Mary get over
this bro you me give me some [ __ ] be
staying medicine somebody put some
calamine lotion on this too bro you need
to come on Brian calamine lotion all
over your face dude you don't know it
dude be milk you milking bees my god
dude you guys got to grow up around here
yeah we do me we all do dude were you
out are you at the comic store this week
yup I'll be at the comedy store man I
think I'm back in laughs act on Friday
are you this right an X right I'll be up
there man I'm trying to go to Chicago a
fact you've ever been there no I haven't
been to Long Beach Laugh Factory I'm
trying to go there um and I'm having a
Cole Arbor come on my podcast you've
heard her what'd she do she's funny bro
comedian yeah white girl
but uh I'm bad with names bring up
cherry money then she had the common
story she just came out with this new
thing called in Nicole Arbour Nico le
ARB oh you are do you know so fine
god she's pretty and she's very funny
she's gorgeous
look she's funny she's like really funny
dude she is she ain't got them Titans
there's ridiculous looking dude she
could probably breastfeed herself when
she was about three months brough she
got huge tits
uh Rather's not video of a baby she's
like a real comedian
she she's a personality she's a
personality but she could be a real
comedian cheese oh but she's not up LA
Comedy Store in that Factory
no she does stand-up but not there yet
gotcha yeah but she definitely super
entertaining geez yeah this is Pierce oh
man she got them what a Mullins bro you
know so you have around the podcast she
got them leche watermelons you feel me
boy yeah I feel you bro yeah yeah some
new Tony use at a USDA bank just kept
screaming get in there and other people
started to scream it yeah that's I've
been getting some good videos man if
anybody is a good get in their video
send it to me on insta please do
especially a UFC event yeah we post that
[ __ ] we need that I had one guy
legitimate DM egos feels right man you
need to check the mirrors in your house
[Laughter]
[Music]
just come out and jerk off to me that's
the kind of stuff you're gonna write me
bro you know that guy's obviously
jerking off to you oh there's got to be
some dudes out there that are jerking
off to you I bet that also have wives
you know what you don't think any are
with you especially in the south no
because there's too much religious
pressure down there for men to be doing
that no see but I think they do that in
the in the privacy of their homes
oh no you don't see I feel like the
southern they get done watching NASCAR
and then they gather around watch your
podcast oh man
now you don't know a lot about a lot of
stuff because what happens is
a lot of dudes in upstate New York I bet
they're just grilling [ __ ] hotdogs
and inside though not out yet oh yeah a
lot of dudes with [ __ ] neck tats bro
jacking off to me oh yeah but then they
all go their separate ways and jackoff
yeah like there's a shame though y'all I
brought to you about 10 I see about 10
you're gonna go work on my car you know
but they don't even have cars yeah dude
you guys always talk about jacket off
any boys on that the Rat King brought
that [ __ ] in try not to jerk off every
time I come in here it came in here
horny bro I am about this poor girl time
with some prostitute yet on the show God
you don't remind me about all of this
that Prius of prostitutes away from my
studio do it if they had a car that ran
on straight body comb bro
she would be first team all body no I'm
saying that I'd spray into that thing
every morning bro fill the tank up okay
with that bra that ran on semen in the
future oh all right well don't don't
refer to her as a car that you'd spray
up with block no not her if that an
actual car Jesuses she's a human being
who I respect but if they had a actual
car that ran on but that that body seed
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] you get to
work him back by man we ought to get out
of here you know yeah yeah I get two
more shows to do how you do yeah Wow oh
no no can I get the grind is real
brother dude I need to learn if I want
to start learning more about him I mean
like what do I start watching you know
do I have to start like a historical
match is that you should start off with
oh yeah you get UFC fight pass you'd
look like you want like classic you want
me to give you like ten fights you need
to watch yeah yeah what do you wanna
know yeah that's me questions yeah maybe
I'll do that
yeah don't text me like that crazy girl
but yeah we'll figure it out wrestler
you're just laying mats in your yard
just doing body rolls out in the yard oh
wow that's great
thank you guys so much man thanks for
have
to the best man thing it filling in and
thank Brian for let me sit in a seat for
today and not the tiger you go see this
man yeah thank you guys and chin thanks
for having me and man I appreciate you
you mean Cal give him give him your date
son yeah Calgary man June 15th and 16th
I'll be out there so come out here and
get some of that uh that [ __ ] heat
that full body heat I'll be at Cherokee
Casino and that's June 9th and then I'll
be at Imbler brewing and that is a June
23rd and then Charlie good nights up
there in Raleigh have you been there not
have not Raleigh North Carolina and
that's June 20 light when Tia thand 21st
so I'm excited about getting back
getting down there and in North Carolina
and seeing what's going on for sure I'm
sure you see some care cuts that yours
out there we can they get tickets that
you can get them all at theof on calm
slash tour tou our go see this man if
you listen show go see this maze when
the funniest in the world he's also our
guest of the year last year you will see
what you do this year be coming in with
heat son the racking a messing around
this is the fighter in the bond we're
out this Grasim that's awesome bro if
you're watching this it's all possible
to one of our main sponsors now on a
ball I'm telling all no bull audiobooks
are Bo's offering our fans a free
audiobook
with a 30 day trial membership just go
to audible.com slash T fat K all
lowercase and browse the on that
selection of audio programs download a
title free and start listening right now
it's that damn easy recommend a book you
want me to recommend a book to you guys
there's so many born standing up with
Steve Martin my personal favorite they
have millions go browse it yourself any
genre anything you want bloggers they
got it all go to audible.com slash T fat
cake
all or kiss or text e 5k - 500 - 500 to
get started today
enjoy